Chúng ta là truyền và dương trông,
đông thuộc trên bây giờ các bạn ở Thuyền,
tổing đây nổi tiếng và teren và đạt được thuật là rất thông.
Đông thuật nhấn mạnh, ông có thể tới lần bát
nếu phân Kện đục tí kế tải đây, ông bài tò.
Nếu thuật được kỳ ilk là mà bát, tôi có thể sẽ đến
họ muốn tự có mạc, quống theo phát biểu cũng traam Chúau dởi
bên ngoài nhà trắng.
Coroner đồng ý vệnh sau rú rộng là bà,
dùm chương cấp chỉ tiếp qu Het hệ 2 bản trưởng đi càng.
Vì ấy, Râm chưa được gia phần huổi chính cứu về tuyên mỗi này, chưa đó ở tay Râm nhiều lần khẳng lệng,
chưa chính hẹp nhé của mình mà hủng bếng hoa bình và quên làm sao u renu là phông thể chính cãi,
rù sẵn sẵn đàn phán nếu đồng.
Cái quên tính vụ cửa của các quan năng lượng mình tự của tay i ai ai ai ai ai ai.
I Râm hiện sửu khoảng 4,000 kg của renu làm sao ở nước sống ở phần chăm.
Các quên đàn phán gần lên giống như I và I Râm tại Phà Tức Tham chưa đã đủ phá.
Hãy ai bên có mất đồng vì thời hạn hạn chế chương trình hảm nhé.
Chúc khi đó, Washington tính tụi yêu cầu tay Râm chấm rất hoàn toàn khả năng phát triển bụt giạm nhé.
Nông thời tụt đầy cứ trị dạm sát chạch chạy hơn.